Just get the child when I talk to him.
You know, just like, as a camera-person
this should come naturally to you.
We don't know how good we have it
right here in America.
That's true.
You can be whatever you want
to be right here in america
it can't get much better than that. A lot
of a lot of countries
can't do that you know. You're dealt with, dealt with
what you have and that's it.
Yeah.
Um.
What about Germany?
I have no idea.
uh Germany is like such a great country
yeah? I don't know much.
Um.
Spreckenzie deutsch?
Nein?
That's about all i know.
Well I think America is better than Germany
America is better than Germany. Home of the free.
Land of the brave.
Yep absolutely.
Positively.
Absolutely.
Rock on.
Thank you for uh you know being a part
of the American economy. I'm Hans.
I do stand-up comedy and I live in a van
I  need a realty.
Yeah?
Can you realty me up?
All depends on what you want.
I want to not be cold
anymore
I don't even know what to say to that.
Do your homes come with heating?
They do come with, they do come with
heating yeah.
I'm sold